What if someone screams in the middle?
That is not the audio.
That's real.
That's the real thunder.
Get your
little ear to sleep.
Why can't there be seagulls?
What's wrong with seagulls?
Don't you like the seagulls?
Isn't it relaxing?
It can rain when there are seagulls.
Okay, the
sirens are definitely the audio.
Why are there so many sirens in this audio?
The BGM is too loud.
Is it really?
Is that butter?
It's so crazy.
The streets are flooding a little bit.
So today I will not go out
with Kyoro.
Yesterday we
went to a restaurant and missed everything.
We were inside in a restaurant and it rained while we were there.
It was done, so it was good.
How is my voice by the way?
Do I sound okay?
I'm sorry that it's not the in-both-ears type of ASMR, but...
Glad Wawa didn't vacuum you up.
I mean, she did a little, but I'm too strong.
I'm too powerful.
Monomito.
I have some things too for maybe ASMR.
And I also have...
I was a little...
A little stressed about...
About this stream.
So I didn't eat breakfast.
It's
because my volume was low.
Is it still too loud?
Okay.
Me
crippled ASMR.
No, I have a yogurt right here.
Cough drop.
Me ASMR as a hair stylist.
I have scissors.
Wait, let me go get them.
6 to 1.
I
have wheeled scissors.
I feel I must have a southern accent.
It's my favorite VTuber made turquoise real life.
Thanks and good night.
Good night.
Sweet dreams.
I almost knocked over my mic.
Oh my...
What the?
Was that a cat?
I wish there was a cat.
Cat in my room.
It is in your ear.
You know what I mean?
What I can do is this.
Hold on.
Let me try something.
Am I in your left ear now?
No.
I hear someone walking.
Creepy.
Get out of my stream.
I'm still getting my cough drop by the way.
Static.
I kept using the scissors and now I'm bald.
I also have other accessories.
I have...
I've just dropped my mic again.
I also have a used sock.
It's like my softest sock so I used it.
For this too.
It's multifunctional.
I wore it yesterday and then the day I use it for ASMR.
But
this is the main event.
Is this ASMR?
You're
doing great, sweaty.
Can't
there be the C?
What's
wrong with the C?
Can you whisper the ingredients of oxy?
Okay, this is from...
Surf...
Surfactants.
Thank you so much.
How does OxiClean work?
OxiClean?
For milk?
Anyone who's tried our products.
Mindy
Mae is here.
Ask them how.
You
ask someone if they're not sure if it works.
Or ask them how it works and they won't be so sure.
The answer is simple.
Oxygen.
The
20 years ago, scientists came up with Oxygen.
A way to harness the power of Oxygen.
Sorry.
Can you guys hear my computer?
Not really?
Okay, good.
I also have to use as ASMR.
Turn the BGM down even more.
So
I have some yogurt here.
Where'd I put my spoon?
Oh, here we go.
So basically, this is my favorite yogurt to get every time I'm in Japan.
So it has chunks of aloe in it.
And I get it for breakfast, like, all the time.
Itadakimasu.
Yummy.
No, you can't have some.
Little,
oh my gosh, cherry.
Thank you for the pep.
It's really embarrassing.
Can you hear me chewing it?
Hold on, I'll get a chunk of the actual...
Did you make, did you hear me gulp?
Not so much.
Okay, a little bit.
Oh gosh.
This is nice.
I'm not even wearing my headphones.
Yippee.
I guess that
doesn't matter if she's turquoise.
I'm not turquoise.
I am not turquoise.
Don't let Takanashi Kyoro gaslight you.
I am mint.
I am not turquoise.
I am not mid turquoise.
I am
don't let Takanashi Kyoro gaslight...
Okay, I'm sorry.
I was laughing so I had to mute.
I actually really like that song when she sang it.
I think there
are many things that you want me to say and do the ASMR sounds.
Thank you.
Hello.
Not minto.
Yes, minto.
Mid turquoise channel.
This is a mid mid channel.
If you want turquoise...
Wait, turquoise is a what?
Mid turquoise sounds like a Steven Universe.
Hayden, thank you for the...
There's this turquoise mid cosplayer outside my window in the rain.
Watch this, watch this.
It's kind of spooky though, isn't it?
So spooky.
Okay,
there's a small Super Toad's better mic.
Would he be the better mic?
Is my mic not good?
Is
my mic okay?
Come
too embarrassed.
To try it.
Do a silly roleplay.
RP ASMR trying to sell me on extending my car warranty.
Here goes to mid.
Everybody else, they're unpredictable.
You can be the best driver in the world.
Here, come here.
Let me show you this.
Look right here.
This is the best warranty you'll ever...
This
is the best warranty you'll ever...
I'm gonna say this nice and slow for you.
Right here, okay?
I'm gonna say this in a way that...
It's an offer you can't refuse.
Isn't that just what makes you melt?
Thank
you.
This isn't about...
No, no.
The extended warranty.
It costs so much time.
We offer the best of the best
insurance.
One in a million.
This is a phone call.
No, it's not.
Could you just let me in?
Could you just...
Lifeforce there.
I'm a pretty ugly ghost, you know?
All we gotta do is get you to sign the dotted line.
And then I'll just, uh...
You know...
You won't even feel it.
You'll just feel like a little woozy afterwards.
Maybe.
Lifeforce.
And you get the best warranty of your life.
And ghosts...
You know, I have to feed on your lifeforce a little bit.
Done
your lifeforce a little bit.
Oh,
is that...
Gochisousamadeshita.
Thank you for the lifeforce.
Thank you for your service.
And, um...
Itadakimasu.
Back to my breakfast now.
I just got here.
Am I safe?
No.
I am an evil ghost after all.
I think yogurt was not good for me to have for my throat.
Because it's making me like...
It's the dairy, you know?
It's making my throat
like...
And giggling about it is perhaps the best possible result.
I want to succeed.
The good ASMR that helps you go to sleep.
Do you guys feel relaxed from this?
Are you feeling relaxed and sleepy?
I
did the night shades.
So that it was dark in my room.
That's really relaxing.
Do I listen to ASMR?
I listen to...
Actually, there's a YouTube channel I listen to called ASMR Twigs.
And it's basically a girl and her sister.
And they go to hair spas and massage places in Tokyo.
And their videos are so relaxing.
And my headphones maxed and it's perfect.
Good, good, good.
I have difficult news.
This is really cute.
Shut up.
Hack up.
No, twigs.
Twigs.
Like the candy.
Twigs, twigs, twigs.
And not some of the blue archive ASMR tricks.
I'll be honest.
I get embarrassed listening to those kinds of things.
So...
I don't.
I don't ever listen to them.
But yeah, ASMR twigs.
And then...
Recently in Tokyo.
So...
Sorry, I keep forgetting sometimes to go back left and right.
To
her head spa.
I'm so excited.
Yeah.
I'm so excited because my ears are
so relaxing.
But if you want, like, sexy ASMR...
I don't really...
I don't...
I...
What is your favorite sexy ASMRist?
But it's also hard, right?
Because on YouTube, those things are typically...
They think I'm too sexy in this.
Am I being too sexy in my ASMR?
Just
too sexy?
Oh
my god.
This is too much for us to handle.
Okay, I'm gonna get a channel strike.
The Chinese sexy ASMRist.
Only moderately sexy.
Why is this ghost hunting my ears?
I'm hunting your ears.
I'm so close to your ear.
This is where I can get the live voice from.
I'll just suck it out like that.
Does the wax actually work?
No, this is my favorite flavor.
I used to eat the wax on those wax bottle candies, you know?
Did you ever have those as a kid?
Where, like, you'll...
It was a bottle of wax.
And then on the inside was, like, a fruity juice.
And I didn't know the wax was bad.
I would just...
You know, I'm just giving you this warning.
Please, don't.
If only you knew what kind of ASMR stuff is out there on YouTube.
I know.
I just... I
thought you were supposed to eat the wax.
Now I'm second guessing.
I'm listening.
Wait, second guessing.
I love it.
It's
getting too sexy.
I
know you get so embarrassed, but...
This is true.
This is peak woman.
Eating wax.
Selling car warranties.
To
do like those ear cleaning places.
What if it's not just ear cleaning?
Like what if it's a sexy ear cleaning?
I don't think I'll be able to help.
I'm scared.
And also, what if they pull out a worm?
It was living in there and I'm getting really scared.
I don't want to live the rest of my afterlife.
Knowing that there was a worm in my ear.
If there's any worms in your ears.
I'm eating them right now.
So don't worry.
All
the earworms in my ear.
But you don't have to worry.
Because I'll clean them out for you.
Hold on, I'm gonna scoop out your earworms.
Let's get the left side first.
Okay, hold on.
Let's try the right side now.
There's a worm in there.
Oh, there's a whole family of worms.
I successfully cleaned your ears.
How do you feel?
Do you feel refreshed?
Without
the worms, I'm lonely.
Don't worry, I just made room for the spiders.
Isn't this so relaxing, you guys?
Rain
of spiders.
SHA music Rain of spiders.
MAmagici SPIDER
MAGAZINE She's like, you sure drink a lot of apple juice, but it was all you could drink, so of course I was going to get my fill of apple juice.
The snake called howl when he saw me.
Stop, you're going to make me blush.
Stop.
I'm actually at my thing.
She sent me a... she was like, hey, I have this snake picture, but it's kind of not safe for work.
Is it still okay if I send it?
I was like, it's too NSFW for me.
So she sent it.
And I was like...
Fujo and Yumejo for snake.
Life is so good.
If it shows up in your timeline, I'm sorry because I favorited it on me.
I get to eat everything because I'm Yume, so I'm just like, if I see, you know, a good thing.
But if I see, you know, like a berry.
Or something like with Otacon or whatever.
I'm just like, this is so good.
So I'm just eating everything, baby.
Do you guys want to see the picture?
Hold on.
Actually, I feel like it will be gone.
Since she's the one that sent it to me.
You know, I...
Actually, I've liked some pretty...
Oh wait, this post is from a long time ago.
Okay, sorry, berry.
I'm putting you on blast.
Okay, here it is.
Here's the tweet.
How did you find this?
I don't know how she found this one.
I wonder if she just likes the artist.
I can't tell.
What do you guys think?
Oh, I didn't send it.
Sorry.
Here you go.
I am normal.
I'm normal.
Left or right?
Left.
Because I love Blisken.
I love Blisken a normal amount.
You know?
My favorite thing is that Barry was like, is this too much to send to you?
And here I am just linking it in my chat and saying, here you go, guys.
Everybody can enjoy the Snipples.
And
I need some, if you guys could just send some offerings for me besides this yogurt.
Eat
my breakfast, finally.
Even though it's almost 1pm.
I
hope you guys enjoyed this.
How do ghosts get hungry?
Oh, we can.
Can I request some quick go-go-go?
What is a go-go-go?
Oh, yes, we have to rate the go-go-go up to sleep.
Yes, someone requested.
Okay, okay.
We have a
first go-go.
We'll do some sort of special 250k stream at some point.
I'm not sure when.
Oh, just say go-go-go-go-go-go.
Sell go-go.
This is a story called, go the fuck to sleep.
Page, stop.
Are you kidding me?
I have to wait for, unlock this page after an ad, skip ad, skippa-skippa.
The
cats nestle close to their kittens now.
The lambs have been laid down with the sheep.
You're cozy and warm in your bed, my dear.
Please, go the fuck to sleep.
I have to wait for an ad.
Skip ad.
The
windows are dark in the town,
very last book, if you swear.
You will go the fuck to sleep.
The eagles who soar.
Oh, shit.
The eagles who soar through the sky are at rest.
And the creatures who crawl, run and creep.
I know you're not thirsty.
That's bullshit.
Stop lying.
Lie down and sleep.
The wind whispers soft through the grass, hun.
The field mice, they make not a peep.
It's been thirty-eight minutes already.
Jesus Christ, what the fuck.
Go to sleep.
Froggy has made his last leap.
Help them.
The owls fly forth from there.
They soar and they zeep.
Sweep.
A hot crimson rage fills my heart, love.
For real.
The cubs and the lions are snoring.
Wrapped in a big snuggly heap.
How is it you can do all this other great shit, but you can't lie the fuck down and sleep?
The seeds slumber beneath the earth now.
And the crops that the farmers will reap.
No more questions.
This interview's over.
I've got two words for you, kid.
Fucking sleep.
Gosh,
I was reading it and then an ad popped up.
Hold on, I have to wait ten seconds again.
Reclines in the shimmering jungle.
Oh, simmering jungle, sorry.
The sparrow has silenced her jeep.
A cure-stuffed bear.
I'm not kidding you, shit.
Close your eyes.
Cut the crap.
Sleep.
Hold on one second.
It's almost done.
The flowers doze low in the meadows.
Oh, sorry.
Am I on one ear this whole time?
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I can't see it, so I didn't know to change it.
Sorry, sorry.
The flowers doze low in the meadows.
And high on the mountains, so steep.
My life is a failure.
I'm a shitty-ass bear.
Stop fucking with me, please.
And sleep.
Sleep.
Skip ad.
The giant pangolins of Madagascar are snoozing as I lie here and openly weep.
Sure, fine, whatever.
I'll bring you some milk.
Who the fuck cares?
You're not gonna sleep.
This realm is all I can remember.
Your furniture.
Oh, crappy and cheap.
You win.
You escape.
You run down the hall as I nod the fuck off.
And sleep.
Free and dazed, I awaken.
Define your eyes shut, so I keep.
My fingers cross tight as I tiptoe away.
Fucking.
Asleep.
Popcorns in the microwave.
Beep.
For
letting me whisper in your ear.
Thank you for signing your soul away in the, um, warranty.
Thanks for feeding me
sweet dreams.
Don't let the worms bite.
She
wants to use this for sleeping.
Which if you do, I'm not sure what.
But, uh, here.
Oh, oh.
I made that dress one more time.
She's going to use it a little.
A little something.
It's so beautiful.
Oh!